actualmente Cuál es el estado y la
protección que daca le da a esos miles
de migrantes que cobija
esto en este momento para las personas
que tienen daca a nosotros podemos
seguir renovando nuestros permisos de
trabajo ahí y tener un poco de
protección contra la deportación Aunque
desafortunadamente nuevas solicitudes no
están haciendo aceptadas pero la gran
urgencia y la incertidumbre es que
desafortunadamente el programa de daca
asigue bajo batalla legal eso es un
programa que
y uno que nos da mucha incertidumbre no
Sabiendo si vamos a poder seguir
renovando o no en los años que vienen
Bueno A qué se refiere el presidente
biden con encontrar una solución a largo
plazo para los soñadores
yo cuando dacas inició hace ya once años
era un un programa atemporario podríamos
a nosotros como jóvenes indocumentados
a aplicar agarrar permisos de trabajo
pero la el plan siempre era que el
congreso necesitaba actuar para poder
darnos a nosotros un camino a la
ciudadanía andaca no nos da la
oportunidad de agarrar un permiso de
trabajar pero no nos da a un camino a la
ciudadanía o siempre tenemos que seguir
renovando cuando el presidente bailen
habla sobre este esa solución permanente
habla del de la necesidad del Congreso
de los Estados Unidos que actúe Con
urgencia para para por fin darnos un
camino a la ciudadanía que daja
desafortunadamente a no nos da y nunca
fue entendido a darnos bueno Y usted ha
estado mencionando algo de esto cuál
sería el futuro de daca de llegar un
presidente republicano a la casa blanca
tras las elecciones de 2024 porque
recordemos que Trump quiso acabar con
este programa
eso es exactamente correcto
desafortunadamente ya hemos visto que
podría pasar si hay un un presidente que
quiere acabar con el programa Y es que
lo va a tratar de hacer han
desafortunadamente ahorita daca está en
una batalla legal en las Cortes
federales aquí en los Estados Unidos ahí
hizo lo que quiere decir es que en
cualquier momento vamos a oír de una
corte es posible que se apele Ah pero la
realidad es que para nosotros vivimos a
debajo de esta incertidumbre a cada día
nunca Sabiendo si una corte nos va a
quitar ese permiso de trabajar de poder
ir y ganar para nosotros y nuestra
familia hizo por eso es con tanta
urgencia a que celebramos estos once
años pero también sabemos todavía lo que
necesitamos hacer para que se haga algo
permanente